un juez de La Paz ha ordenado la
detención preventiva por cuatro meses
del gobernador de Santa Cruz el opositor
Luis Fernando Camacho en la cárcel de
máxima seguridad del país de Chon
chocoro que está ubicada a unos 30
kilómetros de la paz en el altiplano
boliviano durante la audiencia El fiscal
ha argumentado que Camacho en el año
2019 ha entrado en colusión con las
fuerzas armadas y con la policía para
establecer Un gobierno Cívico militar en
beneficio de la expresidenta Yanine añez
Camacho ha intervenido brevemente en la
audiencia para señalar que no se rendirá
y ha pedido a la población seguir
luchando para evitar que en Bolivia
Según dijo se instituya una dictadura
como la de Nicaragua o la de Venezuela
los abogados de la acusación han
argumentado que Camacho no tiene
domicilio ni trabajo conocidos para
pedir su detención preventiva Pese a que
es de público conocimiento que es el
gobernador de Santa Cruz y que tiene
familia y casa en ese departamento por
este mismo caso debo decirles que la
presidenta Yanine añez Está detenida
también preventivamente Durante un año y
nueve meses sin embargo ella sí ha sido
condenada por otro caso también que
tiene que ver con el año 2019 entre
tanto Les informo que en Santa Cruz
continúan las protestas de hecho durante
esta jornada se cumple un paro cívico de
veinticuatro horas en rechazo por la
detención del gobernador Camacho los
dirigentes de Santa Cruz consideran que
el Gobernador ha sido prácticamente
secuestrado y de manera violenta y por
eso han ingresado en estas protestas que
incluye bloqueo de carreteras